hello there reject nation my name is
Greg Alba my name is John old Humphrey
it's another night after Greg has a big
dinner takes a shower he's ready to go
to bed finds out a men and black
international trailer dropped trying to
capitalize on all that Marvel action
happening this weekend Valkyrie and Thor
speaking of which you guys are gonna
check out our Avengers endgame
non-spoiler review we are extra extra
careful but make sure II won't spoil
Jack about it primarily share feelings
on the film also I want to thank
everyone who watched it because there's
a three minute opening sketch that are
beginning a ton of praise for what we
did for it's the last sketch that we are
doing while living together in this
apartment I want to thank you everyone
is there to watch it and if you haven't
watched our review go check it out if
you don't even want to watch the review
because you're trying to stay clear of
any opinions just watch the opening
sketch that'll make us feel even the
happiest wow they're doing this reaction
just a brother Avengers in-game video
what more motion eyes other videos oh
god let's watch super cut let's watch
this trailer which is our men in black
is actually from a marble property isn't
it
we and it covers over covers oh cool how
interesting I like to care I've already
liked it a lot
[Music]
[Music]
really should be here adorable
I thought Will Smith's Matheny was gonna
pop a secret no oh yeah one more thing
down it falls on the stock does snap
over there with you 30 second reaction
review certainty film TV show and/or
trailer you can post your own reactions
over there as well we officially have
500 Stardust posts after a covering of
Avengers endgame but a little bit if you
follow us today the whole thing is
completely free to download and use for
the rest of your life at least that's
what they're telling us talking about
this I thought this trailer was so much
better than the first one because hey if
you guys start reaction to that one who
are like big fans of it it's kind of
like whatever it's not about this
trailer I felt he did show us more it
took its time more - it's kind of a long
trailer action - yeah I feel like we
actually got a taste of what's really
gonna make this one work
yeah I mean this one really brought me
more of the intrigue and more of the
discovery that men in black the first
time brought around and I came out in so
many different ways whereas in the first
trailer just felt like oh it's kind of a
comedy that sort of men in black it's
referential to men in black it's wearing
the suit but it's not really embodying
in this trailer had more of that it's
not being lived in through a suit yet I
think the lot of that comes with a cool
backstory with Tessa Thompson I liked
her backstories like the coolest thing
in the world but I actually do like that
concept of yeah what are they called -
neuralyzer zan your Alya the neuralyzer
of how it erased her parents memory but
she just happened to be there and you
would think about that sometimes like
wouldn't there be like some people who
just happened to this based on home yeah
yeah
so I like having that concept and that
whole thing of I found you talking to
whatever you know an anemic fees
character was amenable I know the
replacement for who said yeah yeah it
made it it made that so much stronger
for me because in the first favor I was
like oh cool she's like really capable
of excited about this
I didn't really get why it was that
important to her then this really
conveyed that to me the first trailer
felt like they were trying to pitch this
more as like still the dude movie Donnie
men in black movie yeah but this one
felt more like Chris Hemsworth is
actually more of the supporting
character disa Thompson's the lead and I
like their dynamics here a lot I
actually liked the self-awareness and
some of the humor with the more it's
like feminist comedy where did she go so
like go in the driver's seat yeah I'm
driving but then I like the the punch
much of the joke that oh it's actually
there in London in history well yeah
it's actually clever unlikely Chris
Hemsworth incredible comedic delivery
aware the men in black men thumbs up
that looks very funny it doesn't just
feel like Thor and Valkyrie basically
yeah he kind of feels like a mixture of
Ragnarok Thor meets a little bit of
Ghostbusters knew it's his new brand
yeah whereas Tessa Thompson feels
doesn't feel like Valkyrie to me at all
here no that's like the thing that's
weird to me about this is it seems like
Chris Hemsworth is kind of getting
molded into this type right now or maybe
I was like I'm still having a fun time
with it and it seems like maybe he likes
playing it too whereas Tessa Thompson I
really appreciate that even though she's
acting on this scale doing all these
huge profile movies it seems like she
plays a relatively wide variety of
characters Terk within those roles I
mean you know they've all got spunk in
some way but this doesn't remind me of a
lot of her other roles and so I don't
yeah again just feel like I'm watching
Valkyrie or something like that or sure
sure I notice there's a lot less Liam
Neeson in here I can't pinpoint why I
was is there something that he did in
his personal life that he unnecessarily
revealed I haven't kind of put him in a
bad light because he was in the first
trailer a lot hmm no I haven't read one
thing about him recently at all or had
many arguments about it with family and
friends and alienated people in my life
I did hear I did hear something what you
didn't tell me - why is his last movie
didn't perform so well though oh that's
what about where he's killing people in
the snow yeah but that's it was
surprising but you know that Liam Neeson
never even had the thought of doing
kamijo Nanjiani is the new puppy yeah I
can't remember if there was a different
comedian voice in the other trailer but
I think they know bird
they have anything yeah no no I think
there are gonna be a couple of those
guys popping up but he does look funny I
mean you know as the new yeah like you
said Frank the dog or whatever you know
that new yeah it's the replacement or
the new michael stuhlbarg or whoever I
also like it via the villainous element
like the first men and the first one was
you know the cockroach with wood and
then and then the second one was Laura
Flynn Boyle and all right this one we
don't see who the villain is necessarily
like did we I didn't feel like we did we
said like the the opposing force cuz
it's the shape shifter guys who could
take on anybody's for and all but I
don't have one facing test I like the
concept of the villains two of you know
that moment when they're on the jet ski
flies you know all they're gonna be gets
all the men in black that's actually
something else that I really like here -
where's the first trailer really felt to
me like it was trying to be men in black
this one I felt more of its specificness
more of its will make some more unique
and different especially in its design
choices I felt a little bit more lizard
like alien creatures here it's a cool
elements to with you know the taxi yeah
yeah yeah Star Trek is a good call but
yeah the taxi to those like machines
that aren't what you think they are
because they're always guns the guns
well in yeah and those to me are beats
where I'm like I really hope that they
find a creative way to introduce those
and not just be like hey it's a black
thing they get the big guns
yeah this movie looks like a lot of fun
not like yeah I didn't see it but it
looks like a left one alright guys well
before we wrap this video up I would
like to give a paid for the day
shout-out to a man named Daniel
Gallacher Daniel right here I have your
Twitter and I'm gonna screen record this
buddy he follows us and now
you we're gonna tweet so often now we
have to go back through everyone else we
shout it out and paste we follow them
and we prove it because we are all about
transparency what are you excited about
James Bond apparently a lot of blonde on
your profile oh wow Mark Hamill
okay wow you look like you have a very
engaging Twitter a lot of unique posts
yeah you really expressing your voice
out there and I appreciate that about
you man never never stop the dream never
stop never stop ever
guys you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification about
make sure to go check out our Avengers
end game review follow us on Stardust I
have an Instagram and Twitter so does
John huh you know just go find a
youtuber with like no followers and
watch their videos cuz they're cool too
you know real people that's what YouTube
was made for yeah bye
[Music]